[Music]
okay good afternoon everybody
so I'm Narula main I work as a front-end
development lead in credits ways and I
am a conference speaker also I used to
talk about micro front-ends progressive
web applications and we have a
co-organizer of one of the meetup group
called tech boxing appu so yeah please
join and then you come to a talk so if
you're interested
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay agenda since shop you don't want to
talk much on the slides but we
understand that it's good to have a
basic understanding of what is PWA and
why do we need pw8 and the building
blocks which enables building
progressive web applications and then
you will state awake
dive into developing an app or I would
say converting an existing app into a
progressive web app and then we will be
deploying it and testing it across
Android iOS Mac and Windows okay just to
get an idea how many are already
familiar with progressive allocation
what it's all about
okay so how many of you kind of
developed something and so on experience
no that's good so what you are going to
do is we are going to start from the
basics so that everybody gets familiar
and then they can try on their own
what is PWA there are so many
definitions of progressive web
applications so one of my favorite is
this one it's combining best of web and
best of native apps okay so we all know
like the best of web web is like you can
just click a link and access an
application and then you can do whatever
you want and it's like works across all
devices all operating systems so you
don't need to kind of a specifically
download iOS app or develop iOS Airport
native apps and also web is inclusive
everybody in the world can access to the
web so irrespective of whether what
device they have ok I'm the best of
native apps the native apps are really
good I think all of us have used apps
and then we have smart ones tons of apps
on the homescreen and the best part
about native apps are like take you very
good user experience so they also engage
the users like push notification and all
those things which are not available in
their before and ok sure
yep
okay so we have we have just seen what
is pw8 and some of the features of PWA
first of all why do we need PWA so these
are statistics you see the left hand
side is average monthly unique visitors
you see app has a score of seven and the
web has fifteen point seven the reach of
the web is way higher than the app on
the other side average monthly minutes
per visitor how much time they spend in
the web or app you see app they spend
more time compared to the web so why is
it why the engagement is slower in the
web constraints on the mobile web it has
a greater reach but lacks on the
richness the usability the richness and
the engagement is lacking unlimited
access
let's see the constraints on the app
side the native apps now problem with
the native apps or let's say if you want
to use an application in web you just
click a link and then you see and then
you decide whether you want to use it or
not in apps first you have to know the
name you have to go to the App Store or
Android store under here to search for
the application and then you have to see
it and then you have to download it and
then you have to install it and then you
have to launch it and then if you don't
like it delete it so the distribution
problem is there in the native apps
another problem is it's not all like
Singapore and other developed countries
we have a good network conditions in
some of the countries the network is not
reliable so if you want to download and
I have before you can use it I think for
example the 60m B app in one of the
countries we visited took seven minutes
just to download the user has to be
patient for seven minutes to just
download and then launch it and then try
to see if it is useful the storage some
of the users we might have a low-end
devices which may not have lots of
storage so it will be problem for their
mouths phone and the cost of the network
bandwidth the data
okay so that's all so we just want to
cover what is PW a and what we are
trying to do in when one line you are
trying to make the web application
closer the native application and why
there is a need for progressive web
application even though we have a native
mobile apps so now let's see the
building blocks the last few years
lots of good development happened on the
progressive web application side which
enables us to provide features which are
close enough to native apps so I will
give it to you - to talk about the
building blocks which enabled
progressive web applications
and well as different women by now what
do you like yes what more
yeah notifications star bypass are
interacting they talk to you whatever it
is really so you could work on a mobile
app even if you're not connected to
internet you could play games you could
do whatever things that you do on your
app you could interact with it yes
I'm a teacher so they are native so it
has support from the operating systems
whatever docking system or university
has supported so that means essentially
the performance of girls and things are
there and mobile apps are out there with
first class citizens in the whole wide
world right if you have to excel at the
lab okay find it except for the start of
all your apps and if that eyes are
congruent go to the browser and then if
it is not responsive it would look
immediately you would also sort of see
that we have so many rules here and
things that you buy mobile apps are the
minimizations or anything so experience
is minimal I know just exactly this one
action that I think it takes in
somewhere else and they do certain more
actions alright so it gives you
something to work while Web Apps gives
you a lot of features in
things get in there but then there are
few other challenges as well between the
pack maybe perhaps right if you do we
live at the weapon you see you would
have Android developers you would have
us you have different as that usually
you might be using some hybrid software
technologies like the app native or
self-protective but you still are in the
molecule in fact we have to hydrate
wrappers on the top so you teams could
be different and technology choices
secondly as you
perhaps write letters are rather than be
factored in sex whatever commission that
you need is on the circle your English
effected a work is done virtually
accessible by lab it's all up on your
software mobile right so if it's the 50m
VR it has two less there if they are 20
and here everything has been tested and
how much capital Ouagadougou that you
would realize that it sometimes you can
just keep in selected as you know mobile
you're adding deleting so on takes too
much of the space I need space for
engages also cannot be bad and you'll be
engagement so that I provides you the
feature if you might be able to utilize
of you Portugal see of the credits that
you've had and because any and that's
weather is very good because if you have
ability to download it use it I liken it
to that you would replace very few caves
are in thieves and then whatever the
information that we need is both from
the server pretty easy
so can well I have all the features that
canta estate on your Milan's have to be
tracked a bit about that just like you
do with the native app can you give you
push notifications and that essentially
is the cushion what progressive web apps
try to answer and a few building blocks
that you see here this is what the
language stream of providing one there
are many tests and second is the service
Booker them up amethyst is more of a
Jason applying think of it a progressive
rock in a nutshell is nothing more than
HTML CSS and ok and then you have the
gzip file the solution ellipse you start
will see that how you want your look and
feel of your equity how you know by what
will be the icons like how the name
would appear and manifest is something
that gives you the ability to save it on
your mo Fe just like a half so it
appears nothing
these are the settings these are the
emitters these are the orientations and
the disputes that happen when you see an
iphone which has a small name only might
be super small you might be a me has a
little item when you click on that I can
use these flashes been coming over and
then shorten the space of the messages
some images pop up and then Apple comes
up is very responsive you could go
around so all those capabilities are
something that comes with manifest which
is essentially a decent fight and this
haven't been ported it's pretty simple
whatever it is
through this simple key value pairs that
you could define this is what I want
might have to be there so dramatically
pop properties
you just get through and you see that it
just how does it provide you the ability
of a potion
capability it needs to have to yourself
right now my abs are something that say
that that's our something that stay
epistle you request something it
delivers the docile to you executed if
you need something from the EPA to put
all that then how it will affect it
means something to interact with the
soul it means something to stop and say
that if I am NOT offline I will listen
to my what my user is saying recorded
and whenever I get back online I will
send it to the server
and the response back that is the road
of serviceworker it acts as a proxy
between the browser and the web server
it just sits on your browser in the
background listens to all that you
talking to the server regards it if you
are online depending on how you
contribute it could send the response
percent the request get the response
so this is the very basics of course
Elvis Booker's again it's outside of
your app don't it's something to
transfer with your app but it's
asynchronous it's runs in the background
and it does not have access to you Dom
objects so it can not interfere with
what you are let's start up and see this
in action
ok let's go
the first thing we will be doing is
adding the web app manifest so that your
website can be added to the homescreen
like app and then you can verify that in
Mac Windows and I was an Android so
recently the PWA the app manifest
support has been added to linux mac and
windows so desktop also you can have a
app and then you can launch it so we are
going to see that so let's get rid of
the slides
okay so what we are going to do now is
we are going to take an existing app and
add all the progress you features to it
so prerequisite I hope everybody has
gate load version greater than ten
Chrome latest version and maybe people
can write their email address we can
invite them to the slack channel so that
we can copy and paste some of the things
yeah email addresses here whatever they
used for slack yeah okay so if you
satisfy all the prerequisite try to
follow these steps get clone in this one
can able to see from the back logic yes
sure
I think if you just go to the github and
go to the repository
DWA - workshop - 2019 you can get the
URL from there also when you are
and there's not any way to find this
just raise your hand if you need any
help
so once you get the project stall and
start you need to have a Heroku account
so go to Heroku comm and then you can
sign up trying to deploy into the cloud
so that we can access
once you install and start make sure
that you can see the screen
one simplest of her who are you will see
that they cancel each other and that few
other you can use to view it on your
models
let me know once you're done with all
these five steps and then we can take
the next phase of plate out
okay
let me know if anybody is still trying
to finish the five steps anybody still
write trying to finish the Ross five
steps okay cool
okay if you have installed Heroku CLI
then you can do Heroku login from your
command prompt terminal
and then it will ask you for your
credential again you can type it
and that's the next step you go to the
heroku calm and then once you log in you
can see a new project new app option and
then you can call it like SG clinics -
here you can put your name here a short
form
I think the region you can put in the
United States or Europe anything
once we have created the project in
Haruka comm and then from the command
line you can pry this command Heroku get
remote - yay and the username whatever
name you have created you have to give
the same name the third step will attach
your git project with Heroku so that
whenever you push all your changes will
go to Heroku and then it will be auto
deployed
when you look get remote on me you you
should see the Heroku I saw one of the
origin
yes
oh good yes Janie she wanted the same
thing yeah okay
what's that I do
unusually good I have done wonderful
different luggage and then
you are inside that folder okay I think
you're good you can okay can you do the
last command that next one get in okay
all set so I know you can run the last
git push now this will push you a
project to cloud and then you can able
to access it from there
which wouldn't get remote - is it
winning this one okay yes the app is
created just in name it doesn't have any
code right
and then we are touching this place in
the GUI it doesn't have any code so we
need to attach the code and uploaded
there to link your git project with
Heroku that's a step git remote attach
this project attaches your project to
the Heroku and then now you are pushing
the code now the code will go there and
it will take time
still going did you take the version one
or the normal one I think it should be a
normal one
anymore here you should get this and we
can repeat the track it's the completed
core you can refer back now you create a
new project cool with a different name
so let me know once everyone is done
with all the steps and then you can try
to access your Heroku app from your
browser it will be like
yep don't forget to put HTTP because all
the features we are going to put needs
HTTP and then you should be able to see
the same app whatever you have seen
locally
okay my dad kissing
you know I would access it in your
mobile nice can you try to add to
homescreen and it doesn't go to the
magnet yes yes yes you can remove it and
then that's what we are going to do next
so you can also access this URL from
your mobile then see how it looks and
then from your mobile try to add to
homescreen and see what happens
oh you down with this step so you know
okay
are you done with the steps
you guys know the steps
are you messed up
okay try to access the URL from your
mobile
all verify ok this is the one correct
the next step is you created the second
step the third step is Hiroko get
removed
I done it ok can you go to the yeah so
here I did step
hello cool yeah before we get remote
no yeah just a name yep Anto okay so you
have to install the haricot come online
can you go to the browser
okay you need to download this and
install this
I need to download this windows right
yeah this would be downloading yep
tonight that command so he's now John
loading the head of UCLA once it's done
you can help him with the steps once
it's done you can install it it are you
done
I hope everyone is done with the steps
okay we can move on and do our first PWA
feature which is adding an app manifest
and which will help us to add this
website web app into home screen so that
you can launch it like mobile app okay
so RIT is covered
some part of it what are the steps you
need to do so let's look at it again
okay
first go here public index dot HTML and
then you just need to uncomment this
line
okay so then we need to add this
manifest dot JSON file which we don't
have at the moment for that
you can get the file from here
okay once again
go to github and there is a second
project which is a Zeke Linux version
1.1 the whole project and that has the
completed code so don't download it just
take this file and then put it the
public folder so I'm just going to do
these steps just follow me and then you
can do it yourself
okay this file just copy it go to public
folder money first dorje say and then
paste it here
okay and the next step is let's walk
through this file okay the first one is
short name this is the name which will
appear in your home screen so normally
if your app has a bigger name you should
provide a short name so that they the
name it will be displayed in the home
screen of your mobile already a desktop
in in your desktop and name is the
actual name icons so you need to provide
icons with various sizes so that the
operating system will the browser will
decide which icon to pick and then it
will use it in the home screen so we
have mobile life desktop so it's good to
provide a multiple icons so if you want
these icons you can get it from here the
same project version one images so it
has four icons you can download this and
then put it under the same public images
you can copy the whole image folder and
paste it there
so I'm going to do the same step public
images going to copy it
you just need to I think replace the
images here this people is the whole
folder here oh right
okay once you put all the images here so
there's three changes in text or HTML
you uncomment the manifesto Jason
and the second part thing is add this
file manifesto Jason here and then add
the images that's it you can go here npm
run bail
then npm and start server
okay it's already news
okay so let me put the steps here and
then you can follow one by one
step one
uncomment
okay
these are the steps and then you can
access it again and then now try to add
homescreen and then see how it looks
[Music]
from the desktop once we're done it
sometimes you will see resorption
install HT clinics if you don't see this
option don't worry you can go to more
tools and create shortcut and then it
shows this icon whatever we have added
and then also it shows the name this is
a short name which we are given in the
manifest adjacent and you check this box
open ass window then it's coming in a
different window then the browser window
you can select book you can close in a
desktop you will see this SC clinic you
open it it opens here not in the browser
window
exiting is it let me
so I'm Chris
this app open it
okay
so ease it in this perhaps okay do it
again
mortals which is create shortcut click
this openness we have to it
yeah right open it
let's close all the things and make sure
your thing is running para cool
you should access it from here
local localhost 4000 we have intend a
ploy to Heroku so access it from
localhost 4000 create shortcut openness
window you
you already know which is Oh can you use
Chrome yeah yes it tastes I know
okay let me come
I don't see anything after women this is
stuff here
to push my successful
oh yeah okay so do the second one yeah
the point it's fine yeah he just
deployed you npm run build after that
stores over can you close and try again
after this you access the app from
localhost 4000 port number because we
haven't yet deploy to Heroku so you can
access from localhost
Randall
okay
those who have completed this you can do
the next step so you can commit the
changes git commit and then do a get
push Heroku Master
this step will push our latest changes
into Heroku so that you can try to
access it from your mobile phone and
then you can try to do the same at the
home screen and then launch it from a
while
you can commit and then push to Heroku
git push Heroku master
I think we started earlier
to speak already abuse as they will like
that
maybe this like any level if you have
any food you might also see it you'll
need to plan ahead of cou this one now
have an exact idea the orientation is
yes I think that the manifest
destination file has a yes yes option
actually can quickly Google and then you
can try to change it
if you're on an iPhone you can try to
access it from Safari and then at the
home screen
so Android phone try to use Chrome yeah
they're coming yeah for the web browser
icon is incorrect
yes it's not correct can you delete it
and trying it it should go you deploy to
Heroku okay launch it yeah wait
normal it should change did you add the
images
I'll correct okay close all the browser
plug-in Safari yep any tabs open can you
okay
it does just matter you just need to
close this tab for this one and then
should be okay can you apply HTTP yes
please make sure you try HTTP yes when
you access the Heroku
hmm why risk work or something
yeah I'm just simply using energy tools
so which Bush at home
can you play out sometimes comes
let me try you on your lame okay
in the commit command itself you can
give the message can you try again
commit and then - them you can give them
as a state
okay yes Nate push a monster now it
won't wash to Heroku once this is done
you can let us try to access your URL
from
the Heroku URL you can log into Heroku
and then you will have open yes
what's very worldly SG clinics - okay
let me delete my
longer than appointment
can you show us index dot HTML okay
manifest is it under images folder
nobody knows correct okay
I forgot how come to give others
yeah I mean my ways in regard these
icons oh yes
okay for people using iPhones you need
to do one more step
so Apple doesn't respect the manifester
Jason so you have to do they have their
own way of doing it copy this and put it
your in index dot HTML so I will just
put it here
it is the same tag with the different
images
you're able to see an icon in mobile is
it coming
at home
yes
[Music]
I need company off them I think they
just trying lost them
oh that should be okay the first is okay
can I just raise your hand if you're
still doing it okay
anybody else
let's give five more minutes
I'm not walking up
Oh candy boy hack it's a deployed okay
the other night for you the x6
it's a diploid
let's see
clothes under here I'll start again yes
anyone got it working in their iPhone
sorry okay thank ya
yeah commit and deploy
sorry yeah get and commit and then push
Heroku master anybody got the icon in
iphone step compiling okay
we're still trying to deploy and get
oh by the way I have added most of you
to the slack Channel please join so that
I can paste this so that you can just
copy and paste instead of typing
no need Oh what happened suddenly looks
nice good you don't need to run we'll
just commit and then push and Heroku
will do the build and then it will start
it so you don't need to do NP m run
build here slack
have you given your email address did
you receive an email know what okay yes
please join slack so that I can post the
code there no I haven't seen this
cabaret dancer maybe is it a new one
how did it especial for Chloe sorry
slack you should have received the email
not to join
I think slack will send an email
whoever not received slack in wait let
me know
okay so I will give the list one second
I can see one two three four five
please let me know if you haven't
received a slack invite you can write or
if you haven't written your email
address you can also write now
so that we can paste all the code there
and then you can just copy and paste
I'm just
okay
[Music]
yeah
it's just one more two things okay
everybody not just to sentence okay
everyone it's done
iPhone Android desktop cool just few
more things here so you see the team
color so this is the background color
when the launch screen comes if you want
to customize you can change the color
and then you can see the start URL this
is the URL which will be used when you
tap on the home screen icon and then it
will open so that's a URL will be used
here dot means it will use the home URL
which is localhost 4000 or your header
cube calm okay nothing much yeah so if
you are done then we can move on to the
next one okay
all done cool okay the next feature we
are going to cover is making the app
offline maybe you can try now so if
disconnect network and then try it will
fail because there is no offline
capability at the moment we are going to
make it offline capable water it's
[Music]
but installed it you would understand it
just looks like any other thing on your
mobile phone but if you go away with a
bone because what is it it will say
Internet company
smiling
on a flamer my us it looks
[Music]
yeah but in Safari
yeah it's not there
all right moving on to the next section
it's called serviceworker so as we
discussed a while back about
serviceworker right serviceworker is
something that stays with the browser
imagine it is to be a JavaScript file
but which is independent of your
application it just sets at the
background so that nobody knows listens
to what you're talking with the server
just sortin facilitates your records
sense and acts as an interceptor so what
we are going to do next is add a small
serviceworker and see how it behaves the
main reasons to do serviceworker is to
make your app work offline and to make
your app save some information that in
case you are offline whenever you go
back online you don't have to redo it
the app will do its producers for itself
so for that thing what we need to do is
if you go back to your web pack dot
config dot J's depending on the ID if
you search and go to this file the pack
is a kind of library that allows you to
modularize your code and make it more
focus it resolves the dependencies make
certain chunks of it and just organizes
that information in smaller or rather
minified files so it's a pre compiler
and what we are going to use here you
see a few commented lines in line 18 on
your web pack dot config dot J's
uncomment this line which is constant
work box web pack plugin and if you
search
work box
uncomment this block from five seven
zero oops
from five seven zero to five eight two
it is commented five seven zero two five
eight two
and line here line number 18 and from
5-7 zero two five eight to step back dot
config Dargis uncomment line 18 and
command line 5 72 585
and once you have done that sorry
go over and npm build and then PM start
lines to uncomment again line number 18
in website config days and line numbers
570 to 585 see there are no errors
once you do that and launch your program
what you would see is if you do NPM
start NPM run build and NPM start you
could merge the commands and as you
launch your browser on your given port
go to developer tools if you are using
Chrome or ie or Mozilla and go into the
application sections you would see
manifest that shows all the information
that is what you have already added in
the manifest different icons the names
and everything like that and you will
see a file here named service worker dot
GS
within the application manifest and
service workers see if you have that in
your application look through developer
tools now
to make it simpler clearly everyone can
use
not that no here justice
okay you have already built and drives
up see ya
it starts and then give now it's
generating its Auto generation our
generation
yes run star service star okay let's go
back can you close the browser and
reopen
still yeah still not there can you see
the manifest is that fine yeah
okay let's go to your website config
once more and go up do you have the work
the line number 18 we have done
to entertained expertise not as yet
okay all right so I think that is so
in case you don't see it that's not a
problem because we will anyways do the
very initial step to set it up if he
seeds is well and good but it doesn't
hurt so what we are going to do next is
service work as I say it's primarily
just in JavaScript file that essentially
would have certain events that would
intercept what browser means to
communicate with the server and back
it relies on certain oops events named
installed that is event to install the
Service Worker activate
to activate the serviceworker the life
cycle includes installation followed by
activation followed by termination or in
between waiting in case so let us go
through this work cycle and service it's
about adding the road so while you have
added that will show thanks
go to your K index dot GS
window dot add eventlistener
have a load event
while serviceworker is widely supported
not necessarily all the browser
supported so we need to check if the
current navigator that you are using is
supporting serviceworker or not so here
service worker in navigator so if your
navigator currently supports the service
worker
if you navigator a supporting service
worker navigator dot service worker dot
register it needs an absolute path which
we will give shortly this is the promise
that would return a registration object
to service worker
sorry
once you have done this go to your
source folder and create a new file call
it service - worker dot J's
under your source SG - Kleenex under
source create a new file name service -
worker
and add eventlistener install will pass
at the event object
and say console dot log installed
Service Worker
I'm sorry
sorry
the way of you
the you mean this arrow wait until here
is a command to sort of and wait until
whatever follows is executed so the the
event won't end until whatever are the a
list of commands that you pass under it
are executed so this is kind of in at
the construct within which all that you
want to execute and E stands for the
event the event of installation and wait
until is no yeah so III need does not
need to be under any error function
once you have done it you could go back
to your web pack dot config J's there is
there are quite a few things there which
you could get rid of like the new
regular expression fall back
trim your wok box configuration down to
it's much
sorry this
and the generate as GDS tableau method
that you see change it would inject
manifest so we are not asking this very
library to generate a service worker but
a refer a service worker that we are
creating and this would need a path
where to pick a service worker from so
it will be SW SRC
source folder service - worker dot J's
and remove this line of clients clean
okay so you have your service worker in
place we have the web pack config setup
and then we have also added an event
listener for load okay
I'll also add a console here to sort of
and see if the event is being fired and
when the load event and let us see what
happens so I'll just build it and rerun
and p.m. run build and NPM starts over
try it
very well-received psychic just
okay in the Lord event I forgot to give
the path for Service Worker so just add
the service worker name
it's like you you're gonna call be
abased orderly what okay okay yeah yeah
sure
yeah sure yeah so I'll just put
everything on slack so that it's easier
for you to review
I first change inductors JS file in
source adding the windows load event
after that add Service Worker service -
worker dot J's in source directory and
under service worker in service - worker
dot J's write this line of encode which
is the install event and we are just
writing on the console and velocity in
your web pack config
from lines 572 573 and sure they look
like this the back dot config dot chase
so it's all on the general channel of
slack now and once you have done these
things and when you do rebuild NPM run
build and PM run start server
just
senior console if you see messages are
like this in the window load event I am
ready to register a service worker and
install the service worker
and along with it you would see a
service worker available with a number
if you go to application tab in your
chrome developer tools and go to the
service worker you should see a service
worker with a particular number probably
zero or one
[Music]
so
the pack on this last one is the change
about the config file so online 572 582
just replace that
you know that that conflict yeah
so this world walks 5-7 to this whole
object trying to just replace that
object
come on
that should be it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the screen because you get done
no no HDMI box 100k I thought it was
alright thank you can you refresh it
yeah
okay you have received this is something
else no clothes
you don't
okay you see this one is fine so or does
not control
let's go back to the cold inject
manifest this is fine index
serviceworker navigate resistor then
registration
Oh
this could be tricky
lovely
[Music]
everyone can see those three messages or
at least your serviceworker in place
your serviceworker will look like this
it will probably have a number zero one
two activated and is running just
confirm that you have a message like
some number is activated and running all
right cool
once you have done with that go back to
your service worker and we'll add one
more event activate
II rate activated service
I'll put this on slack
and once you do that and you go back to
your browser and refresh it you would
see something like this you would see a
old service worker and new service
worker that is waiting
see if that happens
you're probably zero serviceworker which
would be activated and running and
another serviceworker two or three
waiting to activate once you add the
activate event
there is something very interesting
about web applications now when you work
on web application and when you probably
deploy it into the production
environment and say if someone would be
consuming this application what do you
usually take care of you would probably
ensure that while you really deploy it
no one is online because if they are
online they would be impacted in certain
ways right somebody is working on this
application and here is the new
production release that comes in and
everything has changed the look and feel
has changed that functionality probably
no longer exists or probably whatever
they work they were doing is lost
because oops
there was a bounce right and that's a
common problem that we have with web
applications because we have to plan a
release of every application because
everything is related to the server
whatever request comes needs to go to
the server and the response comes from
there so if there is its downtime on the
server the application is impacted and
the users are impacted the way Service
Worker handles is that whatever
information you think that is important
to the users is you cache it use it from
within the serviceworker
and while suppose you're working on your
mobile and then there is a new app
update usually what happens in native
apps is that you would receive a
notification or you would see it in your
Play Store or App Store that new update
is available for your app but it does
not update automatically you could of
course choose it too but while you are
working at least it does not it's not
like you are surfing through an
Instagram or Facebook oops there is an
update but restart that does not happen
in his native apps so how do we control
that is web app is through serviceworker
to say that as and when there is a new
release that happens part of web
application it has new updated
serviceworker that would wait in the
background till the top a time a browser
is open that
means a client is working on an
application the new Service Worker which
comes with certain changes like we added
the activate event it would not replace
the existing one it would wait until all
the browser's are closed on that all the
clients on this particular browser are
closed so if you just do that if you
have this open and you see something
like this where one browser is active
and second one is currently waiting try
to close your browser see no clients are
active and launch it again
I have to open see that all the clients
are closed
oops
open the app try to see if automatically
updates when you close all your Chrome
instances and when you close it and you
reload it it should ideally auto update
the serviceworker to the newer version
that means that whenever a user closes
the app in the background and when he
opens it against the serviceworker will
be reinstalled and a new version will be
updated whatever changes have been made
so that's the difference between what
installation is and activate Edition is
every time you request and there are
certain changes those will be available
to Service Worker those will be
installed but they would not be active
unless the current application is closed
and relaunched so see if you are able to
do that one thing
honey back once you have done that also
try this if you now go offline you could
do certain really adventurous steps stop
the web server or go in the airplane
mode and try to refresh see if this
works
just close the application and refresh
it see if it works no right yeah it sure
it will is still complain about there is
no internet or the app is not running
yes because we still need to write the
code of how this set fetch because
service worker is not cashing anything
as yet it is just installed but I said
dummy does not do anything what you see
here in your application I want you to
examine that you would see certain ways
of storage
you see local storage session storage
index DB web sequel cookies cache and
application cache primarily what is
being used as a storage mechanism with
serviceworker
our cache storage and index TV these are
all asynchronous storage mechanisms a
while cache storage is an key value pair
that could store the information is wall
information like files that you need to
be reality or or be often available and
index TV for certain operation which are
more structure and more data intensive
other kind of storage are rather
synchronous in nature and they don't
work with serviceworker ideally because
serviceworker in itself is in a
synchronous worker so yeah so ideally
what you would largely be using for
storage mechanism or cache storage and
index TV so now that we know that if you
refresh it
it says the site cannot be reached so
let us try to fix this
so we go back and we say cash and give
it a name
my PWA a cash then go ahead and say what
prize do you want to catch files to
catch have the default have index dot
HTML
okay this is currently what I want to I
just want the index.html to be cached
and that's all and how when will I do it
when I install a serviceworker I would
say I'll do it after this caches is an
API dot open use the cache name from
here - name
it's a promise so whether it will return
you a gash so when that cache opens
cache dot add all files to cache
and once you have done that try to build
and run
I'll put this on slack
out of this like cash
okay once you have done that go back
refresh okay and I think you would have
no serviceworker try to update it in
case there is something that's missing
and then try to go offline probably
bring down the app sorry what did I do
and see what it does
oops buddy
we run again
ah
sorry remove the console I think that is
creating problem
refresh update the cache manually or you
could always choose update on reload so
that your service worker is always
updated see that the word version number
of service worker is updated from
whatever you last one was
and after that take the bold step of
bringing down the server and refresh it
oops
and let's see Skinner
just see once you refresh the
serviceworker you would see under the
cache storage an object created for my
PW Akash if it is not created probably
it's not refreshed and it will have
these two values
and then try to bring down your app and
then refresh
Wow somebody a problem
okay it requires one additional step
because currently it does not know what
to do while we have cashed it but it
does not know that if I receive such a
request what should I do
so we got to tell it that whenever you
go to fetch how do I respond
how should service worker respond it
needs to know so a dot respond red
say if in the caches if you could find
something that matches this request that
I make then whatever is the response
return the response or try to go and
fetch from the server
and once you have done this refresh
update use of this worker if you have
already checked it would be out updated
just ensure it is you could also verify
that you have the latest by looking at
the sources and the service worker if it
has whatever updates that you have made
try to bring down the server and refresh
you would see a blank page but at least
you won't see that the site is done see
if that happens to you
I'll show the code again add the fetch
we are saying that whatever request
comes our way we'll try to return it
from the cache see if it exists in the
catch if it does not exist we'll try and
go and fetch it
run it update the serviceworker and see
if you see a blank page instead of the
site cannot be reached
yes so probably here is before bedrooms
done before back home sick
do you all see blank page instead of the
site cannot be reached No
okay service work is pending let us look
at the service worker what does it show
you have the regiment yeah index okay
the site can be reached and extra testy
Oh Oh I think for you I think you're
missing something here
let's go to application oh you can we
need to see something here so - storage
is somehow not updated so you don't even
see serviceworker
something it's updated 15:25 which is
fine gas storage so you already have you
have added everything yes yes so I think
what we need to do is let's go back to
the service smoker and you already
updated the backpack configure
can we do this in the build folder let
us see how the service works
okay can you delete the bill folder and
rebirth I'll come that side
yes let's go and see him
number eight - what did I do
all remove this concern okay try this
tryna I need to restart just yes
and the thing is that if you go offline
from here serviceworker still has access
to the server because it knows is there
so you have to bring down the
application itself and also do this one
more thing because I think whatever it
is in the history is not cleared so if
you could clear this oh ok ok so once
you launch the application clear the
storage and then try it again so what
you can get
evade until you have go until you are
missing an and
you mdl until
so if you already see blank page its of
no use right you would notice that lots
of things are missing because we are
building this whole work package through
web back and it chunks down all your
JavaScript files and your CSS and
everything so when the service worker
goes and look out for file it doesn't
get the whole file it just because these
are rather auto-generated so one way to
sort of and do it is to sort of end you
have a plug-in for serviceworker in your
web pack config and say that you know in
the runtime try to identify the
dependencies and add all those lists in
your zone self that itself is a tedious
task or you could start up and go ahead
and if you just want to try you could
copy one go back said sorry you could
keep on adding that to your list of
files to cache and you see that it will
eventually get resolved but we don't
need to do that because there is a much
easier way some of you might already be
aware of work box which is a Google
product which simplifies the
implementation of Service Worker
the reason why I showed you this Service
Worker is because this is what how it
actually is work box look makes it look
much more simpler and much more easy to
implement but what what box actually
hides all the complexity so you don't
know what happens on install and
activate and fetch and sync and so on so
that's why was this demo to just
understand what serviceworker and how it
actually functions but actually don't
need to write any of this code if you
are using bug box so I'll quickly show
you that how by just one line of code
could replace all of this
you already have work box installed
through the web.config so I just copy
this one line if you have these things
working rather you could just comment
this out and go ahead and say work box
dot
[Music]
pre-caching
dot free cash and route
self dot underscore three cache manifest
or an MBA
just write this one line and comment
everything else in serviceworker
posting this on the slap
and after this and being run star server
we have already installed a plug-in for
work box in our web config and then we
are already passing it the necessary
parameter to pick from the PCAST list so
ideally when you run it you probably
would see that it is encapsulating the
install activate fetch and all the files
that it deems necessary for caching
which essentially means everything that
is in the public folder of your
application bd-r images be it your
generic J's files or index.html and if
you go back to your browser you refresh
it
ensure that your serviceworker is
updated cache
- of it pretty good
is
one typo there if you are copying from
slack use this instead
note that double underscores here
once you update your serviceworker you
would see messages like this
once you do that if work box is
installed and you bring down your
application refresh it you are still
missing a few things but you will see
most of things are auto drawn without
you writing a single line of code so we
have not we have commented installed we
have commented activate we have
committed commented fetch but yeah it's
everything is then bound within the
world box so it makes life much more
easier when you have to deal with these
things the next thing is different
strategies of dealing with offline
content and online content backgrounds
synchronization and push notifications
but I guess we all need a little bit of
break so let's give it five minutes
all right thank you welcome back so
before the break we saw that how you
could use work box or service worker to
get the offline capability by caching
certain requests there are different
strategies to that you could sort of and
use while caching say what specific
things you want to cache when to cache
there could be things like your strive
sheets and images and so that you might
always prefer to pick from caches and
rather certain transaction requests that
you send to the server you never want to
cache them work box offers you and
serviceworker in turn offers you
different strategies that you could
essentially use which you could define
whether you want to just always look up
for a certain request from cash only or
certain requests from always-on network
or first if it is not available on the
network picked from the cache or first
just go to the cache and while you
refresh in the background returned from
the cache and then update it and keep
the copies updated I show you a very
quick example of what it is I realize
that we are very short of time but I'll
just give you a demo of how you could
really just do one strategy of cache
work dot routing dot
and register route
it takes two to three parameters one you
could give it a regular expression of
the path that you are looking for
and it takes the strategy so workbox got
strategies dot cache first Network first
cache only these kind of things that you
could use to define the different
strategies are available in cashflow
strategy what your service worker would
do is is to first try to pick from the
cache or self if it is not available in
the cache then go to the network for
this particular endpoint or server
resource that we had a questing quick
view if you just go to work box
strategies you would find a quick
documentation here that lists about the
different strategies that are available
the syntax is pretty simple regular
expression whether you are looking for
images you're looking for specific
resources just name it by strategy and
that's the only little code that we need
to write for this we'll see one of the
strategies as we are moved on to see the
background synchronization background
synchronization is something that while
you're on your device and you're working
on something and suppose you go offline
you may lose your work so how to
essentially avoid that and how not to
redo it a classic example is your
whatsapp chats right so you're talking
to somebody and you're sending messages
and everything but if you get into an
MRT and you lose your network your
message does not go through but do you
have to rewrite it
no you just probably write it you post
it it shows that yes it has gone out
from your window but it has not yet been
delivered probably it would get
delivered once you come back in or it
would say still waiting I cannot find
Network so you would see a wait sign in
there but you don't have to really
repost it and how do you bring that kind
of in capability on the web app is what
background synchronization is
all about so let's see an example of
that one for that I would request you to
go to server door GS
let us add a end point here
and call it babe another words this is
what everything is here
Austin with one line subscription I'll
just come and give something else yeah
let me not use this one or you just I'll
just say book what I'll just comment it
out okay so you already have this in b1
it's already on the server right oh
sorry
so in the server are in your server you
would already see this one endpoint you
could come into all the things and let's
sort of and just see that if we could
dot send object back and say call it
looking skaters
as bummed okay and for the time being I
will just make it get instead of post
okay once you do this run the app let's
see if this works
okay go on localhost 4000 our endpoint
is booked see if you are able to access
this
ah
for the time being also come in the app
use HTTP PS it's from line 16 to 23 on
server dot J's just commend it for the
time being and in the book just have a
dummy sample value written restart
see if you see a response coming back
from the server
you share the snippet
yeah
in serviceworker there is order I ignore
this code that was just a sample this is
not related to that so yeah you don't
need to do this as of now suggest in the
book have this one object return and
comment over the HTTPS part okay see if
you are able to see this response coming
from the server all right lovely I just
see everything is updated I'll just
clear your storage and everything so
that we could have a fresh view at the
data that would come in here and then go
back to the serviceworker
let us have a strategy
where we will say this very end point
book new work box strategy now suppose
this is something that we really want to
get delivered to the server and get a
response from the server so in this case
where we want the message to be
delivered for instance we are doing a
bank transaction a cache won't do there
right we really want the network to
reply over so the strategy that we would
use for this booking is network only in
this strategy itself you could use
certain parameters and plug in what we
are going to use is a plugin which is
work box dot background sync
and give it a name
I say sing okay
okay
object ensure this is object
lexpark strategies
network on me yep
so what it will do in turn is it will
call the sink event for Service Worker
and for every request that is routed to
book it intends to go to the network so
nothing should be picked from the cache
itself so this request will not be
cached the serviceworker will always try
to hit the network in case it's not able
to hit the network it will store that
request in a cache and the next time the
network is available it will try to post
that request so let's see if you can
make this work
and p.m. run build and start
so we have already seen that we get a
response from the booking statuses
booked we have cleared our data let us
go back once it's ready and I'll just
see everything is clear
notice that indexdb is currently null it
does not have anything okay and the
service worker just updated
so for me it's installing let's give it
a while
register some type of
Oh
sorry the very name is different
change the regex to reg X yeah take it
back on slack
labeled at
feel free to use node1 if you have I did
not install it
refresh it see the time it was last
updated
it means updating I just updated mind it
is precast six files now what I will do
is I will try to go offline in the
airplane mode but since I'm running this
locally it will still hit my server so I
will also bring my app down and call the
book endpoint see if it does okay
go back
you will see that in the indexdb there
is an entry now
which reads like this
the Rope requests data in the certain
queue sync you name and to this URL and
whatever information we are sending idly
to do post requests there you do sending
a whole body a lot of information but we
just did a simple request which does not
have a lot of information but yes it is
something that is automatically added to
a queue but it is not the serviceworker
is not returning your result it is
storing that so that whenever the server
is back online it could be sent to the
server now if you go back if I go back
and restart the server and also switch
off my airplane mode let's see if we see
something in the console and if ideally
whenever the serviceworker detects that
it's back online it would fire event
background sync for tank request added
to the sync the request failed to replay
because it was still offline and then it
will replay at a certain point in time
it will retry and this would eventually
get clear try it if you could replicate
this in your machines
what's wrong my service book though it
should be like this right yes and then
we have server which is just simply
telling this yes and I running so I just
rewrite this
visitor slow country no it shouldn't be
but here you can still enter sorry yeah
yeah yes I think you should thank you
thank you very much
people seated okay yes you see there to
request yes yeah so this is already sort
of and so when you were off it has
already added it and now as are you an
airplane mode yes so what you could
summon try to do is is to sort of
enforce clear this index TV and then you
go to a plane mode run it see it will
get added here and then as soon as you
turn that off and you come back online
this queue will automatically be cleared
yeah it will listen it detects that you
are not connected to internet as far as
serviceworker is concerned
- okay - give a substitution object to
the server so that the server wants to
use each client and all this information
then what it can forget wine
so they have
[Music]
first let's clean up this class
appointment reviewed ojs under booking
so a few changes you need to make just
uncomment this first if it is commented
and also you have to make sure this
method exists poke appointment
that's it
yeah well good okay the next thing you
need to do is go to server dot Jas
just whatever we have done just revert
this change uncomment those lines
make it post back
okay so if you want I can post this I'm
just going to make small change this
line will not be here in your code I'm
going to make it
subscription checked
okay so I'll just put this in slack you
can just copy and paste
I think it is tone will keep
let me run it so just few changes
appointment review Jas you are just
putting back the methods notification
book appointment and enabling this
method and then server Jas you are
reverting the previous changes and
making it post and this one I have
pasted this in slack you can just copy
and paste okay let's see maybe you can
watch first and then I will send all the
code through a slack and then you can
try it on you around okay
okay so let's go back 4,000
so just for make it everything clean so
update maybe unregister go to clear
storage Clea site data
you start okay good so the scenario we
are going to replicate is let's say you
are trying to book appointment you are
an a.m. at Amati train and then suddenly
the network goes off you want the
appointment still go through when you
are back online and then you want to
receive a notification that the
appointment has been booked or not so
let's see book so this is the normal
case so let's go over this this normal
case confirmed the appointment status
will be confirmed let's switch off the
network make it offline
okay if you're offline you will see this
additional text it seems you are offline
don't worry we can book the appointment
automatically when you are back online
do you wish to proceed we are asking the
users permission whether they are
working to go ahead so they have to
choose this yes at this point in time
when you are doing first time it will
ask you whether do you want to allow
this website to share notification the
client has to say yes then you go next
the final status will be pending but
it's okay but once you are back online
you should be receiving a notification
that appointment has been booked that's
what we are going to try now okay for
that let's go to the code the first step
I prepared a cheat sheet let me face
this don't worry I will pierce the steps
in slack so that you can follow one by
one so first is there is a library
called web push which will help us to
commit the server to communicate with
the push service so you have seen in the
diagram there is a push service for
Safari Chrome and everything we don't
need to write code there is a library
which will help us to communicate to the
right push service and then deliver the
message and also since we are
communicating with the push service so
everything has to be encrypted so the
message has to be encrypted so we have
to use private and public key so the
first step here is NPM install global
web push so let's do it one by one
okay npm install global we are going to
create a pair of public key and private
key okay so this is a second command
web push generate rapid keys yesin so
you get a pair of private and public key
just need to copy this public key
okay so here I have a file called vapid
Keys everything commented out let's
uncomment since I generated a new set of
key let me replace it this is public let
me copy the private
that's it so we have created a private
and public key using the web push tool
and then it is there so we just updated
the rapid keys we will be using it the
server has to have both the keys but the
server has to give the public key to the
client so that the client has the public
key but the server has both the keys
okay
so we have updated we have done with the
step three so now we need to go to step
four when the user clicks the toggle
button notify me when the appointment is
booked so we have to put some code
so this is the code the interest of time
I will just copy and paste so a pieman
review so you have this spot
push notification code here so what
happens when the user clicks the toggle
button Selmy notification
okay
copy and paste it here I will walk
through this goal what it does
so we need to see if the service worker
is there because for push notification
service worker has to be there and if it
is ready and also we are checking if the
push manager is supported the service
worker supports push notification if not
you return it if it supports that's fine
this if check means you say clicked yes
if no means this will be no false you go
here registration dot post manager so
this is the one of when this code
executes user will get a pop up this
website wants you you to send
notification do you allow if the user
says allow then it will come inside if
the user says don't allow it will not
come inside so then after this you have
this the browser will have the
subscription object so the client
authorized
so that's browser will have the
subscription object I am just storing
the subscription object into a state
here so in this web page I have the
subscription object if the user clicks
allow then I have this object and the
next thing I need to do is when the user
clicks proceed so the user is ok to get
the notification so when they proceed on
click
they store booked appointment okay so
this is booked appointment so this
method what it does is it calls API book
dot Jason and it passes the subscription
object the object which user allowed us
to send the notification and the actual
appointment details so along with the
actual appointment details I am also
sending the subscription object to the
server okay so the next thing is server
has to receive this book appointment
request and then send the notification
once it's booked we are going to server
thing we need to change it to API slash
book or we can demo it from here
okay you can change it too okay the
endpoint will come here so that accursed
has two information one is subscription
object and the appointment details the
subscription object is the permission
which client gave so that the server can
communicate the right clients in the
notification so what I am doing is in
the normal case I am returning with this
and if the subscription object is
present that means client allowed us to
send the notification then I'm calling
send notification method I am just
providing as message your appointment is
booked successfully that will be the
message inside the notification and I'm
pausing the subscription object what
this method does in notification let's
go here this is the important part for
sending the push notification just
simple just to luck to three lines of
code let's look at this first web push
this is the library which we installed
NPM installed web push so you can go up
and see so this is the library we used
this library will help us to send the
notification to the client so you just
need to call web post or send
notification you have to post the exact
subscription object you received from
the client so whatever you received from
the client you are going to send it to
the push service what message you want
to send and the additional option what
are the additional options time to live
maybe 60 seconds so it will wait if the
user is not available it will retry so
that time and rapid details this is
where you are giving the public key and
private key for the encryption so all
the encryption you don't need to do this
library will take care of it you just
need to provide private key and public
key so this library will do all the work
for you it will encrypt and then it will
communicate with the right push service
and it will send the notification good
there is one missing part here what is
missing so the client gives the
permission we send to the server the
subscription object and the appointment
details and the server trying to send
that
notification through push service so
there is one missing part
if a client pod client has to receive
the notification and then trigger a
prompt so the last part of the code you
need to go to Service Worker here I will
also quickly copy and paste
okay I will explain this code so push
notification well it any idea will it
come if you close the browser you close
the app will you receive the push
notification app it works in web also it
will happen so we can close the browser
you can close the app still the server
will send the push notification and the
client will receive it that's how that's
why that that's a good thing about the
serviceworker even though the app is
closed the server can wake up the
serviceworker and execute the code for
that app so self dot addeventlistener
similar to fetch we have something
called push when the serve the push
service sends the notification this code
will get executed and it will have a
event then message will be part of event
or data text so this is the actual
message the push service is sending to
the client and then you are just doing
self dot registration dot show
notification and the message and the
title so let's see what is the body
option
I think the title is repeated you can
remove this so you can provide an icon
for the notification and also the
message I am passing it here so that's
it so the main part of the code is this
one the client has to receive the
notification and show it and the server
has to send the notification using this
library that's it
so let's try to run it and then see if
you are receiving the notification and
then you can try it on yourself and then
I will put all the code and steps there
one another thing for testing the push
notification we have to deploy to Heroku
localhost will not work because when the
server tries to communicate with the
push service it checks whether it's HTTP
so localhost it's just HTTP so we have
to deploy to Heroku and then test this
push notification so let's double check
if we have done all the things so
client-side we are receiving the
notification
and then we are showing it perfect on
the server side we are sending the
notification using web push and then we
are providing the option private key and
public key okay and then whenever this
book is called we are going to send the
notification if the user allows tests so
and then appointment review when the
user gives us the permission you are
doing all these things yeah
notify clicked and book appointment ok
let's try to build it
so for this we don't need to build get
status
these are the changes I'm going to
commit and deploy to Heroku
let me quickly double-check this is fine
this is fine this is fine
when I first Lord this is fine
okay cool okay I have committed now I'm
going to deploy to Heroku get push arrow
camasta
meanwhile let me put the steps in slack
okay we just need to do this appointment
review
the client should have a public key and
we need this
so meanwhile you can follow the steps I
posted in slack one two three four
you know
okay
G clinics Heroku
okay so this is the demo so I just click
the button I receive notification once
the appointment is booked and this is
the pop up it will show so the user has
to click hello our block so let's say I
am allowing so then the client browser
has the subscription object which it can
send it to the client okay
the appointment is pending
and let's see the Heroku logs also
okay appointment details and push
subscription object this is the
subscription object and we are sending
using the library
so you see a notification received your
appointment is booked successfully
did you see the notification
so let's try again
okay the second time when you check this
button you will not have that pop-up
coming again because once you are given
the permission so it will take it
so notification received
maybe in the interest of time I think we
got the message but the notification
prompt it did not work maybe if you want
to stay we can stay otherwise in the
interest of time I will push the code
and you can try it on your end okay in
the guitar the second project version
one has all the completed code so you
can always refer to version one and then
you can play it on your end thank you
all